salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous abordons un point en
particulier sur notre cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents
vous nous avez proposé d'aborder notre
côté sens contre intuitif c'est le sujet
du jour
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
oui
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre cinq
expériences expérience une à l'équilibré
expérience 2 les magiciens ont tout
compris expérience 3 les pires
statistiques expérience 4 c'est à vous
expérience 5
les bulles diabolique le tout avec la
présence très appréciée de pierre cros
[Musique]
nous l'avons vu dans les épisodes
précédents notre cerveau contient
beaucoup de données sur le monde et
essai en permanence d'anticiper ce qui
pourrait nous arriver il le fait pour
les situations que nous vivons mais
également pour le monde physique qui
nous entoure et ses règles universelles
pourtant sur quelque chose de si simple
que la gravité il peut faire preuve
d'une logique ou d'un raisonnement
contre intuitif vous allez voir c'est
très perturbant
pierre pour la première expérience on va
faire une expérience sur la gravité très
bien madame c'est pas la gravité de ces
parfums d'insérer situation d'accord
voilà ce qui tombe et c'est un nom ça
d'ailleurs les expériences va faire ses
appels at intégrité la latte intégrité
ces québécois alors cpo québécois mais
j'ai demandé à l'éclairage rat comme des
spécialistes de saiki les québécois
chacun de nous mettre au défi de faire
un truc de tancer grit et pour qu'on
voie un peu ce que cette salutation vous
deux pierres et fabié j'ai une petite
démonstration vous montrez démonstration
qui est plus qu'une ceinture une simple
ceinture comme ça et une cuillère une
cuillère qui a été déformé de cette
façon avec le club retourner à 180°
léger à courbure d'environ 30 degrés
dans le manche comme ça vous serez
probablement d'accord pour dire que si
je t'y la cuillère entremont pouces et
mon index ici si je lève mon index est
bien la cuillère va basculer est tombé
au sol démonstration ça s'appelle la
gravité s'est facilement et
intuitivement vous serez probablement
d'accord pour dire que si on ajoute du
poids sur le bout de la cuillère comme
si par exemple on ajoute la ceinture
comme ça eh ben ça devrait pas changer
la démonstration
et c'est là qu'on fait erreur puisque
lorsqu'on ajoute la ceinture non
seulement pour le bénin
vous remarquez que là qu elle est en
équilibre sur le bout de mon doigt et en
fait c'est parfaitement stable comme
structure pierre favier je vous mets au
défi de reproduire cette expérience de
faire vos premiers pas dans ce qu'on
appelle latence sécurité à ce que
j'avais à s'inviter en fait la taille
des ceintures on en a grosse production
super des cuillères en veux tu en voilà
là c'est chacun pour soi bah je sais pas
on n'est pas obligé d'être dans les
faits par contre regarde ça c'est les
pierres spéciales
donc si tu frottes comme ça elle va se
tordent tout seul il faut qu'on y arrive
en fait c'est pas un battles et de la
coop il faut 15 à new day arrive la
[Rires]
coque
évidemment après on donnera lé cuir
accueillir sans frontières qui récolte
tout d'une cuillère expérience deux à
temps mais je pense c'est un peu pareil
non comme son amie il en reste plus ça a
quand même mais c'est pareil c'est
associées sur youtube ça oui ça pour
l'instant il avait fait part à la
cuillère regarde un non sens de gravité
pourquoi ce parce que la cuillère va
rajouter du centre de gravité vers
l'arabe et utiliser un vocabulaire qui
était étranger n'est ce pas et c'est pas
mal en vrai c'est fait et je pense que
tous puisque tu as fait ton plus à un
peu plus loin ah je sais je sais je sais
que tu essaies de mettre la cuillère
dans la boucle
tu vois c'est une image d'abord tu as
cuillère après la ceinture en cuir à
valhalla satanique eh bien je pense que
l'expérience une valise est validé merci
luc merci luc hockey lui en vrai là il
nous a fait un truc quand je lui ai
demandé de nous apprendre à faire ça
c'est parce que je l'avais vu dans une
émission où ils prennent ça pour les
enfants je me suis d'accord niveau
niveau cp qu'on n'est pas
nouria dessus mais je l' ai vu faire des
espèces de happening hyper
impressionnant de ce côté-là et
[Musique]
il fait plein de figures comme ça mais
c'est juste un présent plus on dire une
oeuvre d'art ce qu'il a fait bravo à lui
voilà pierre tu as découvert à temps
d'asile pour lattes en sécurité l'ate
intégrité que nous venons de voir avec
lux s'appelle latence et great et c'est
l'étude des forces physiques qui permet
de faire tenir de manière complètement
contre intuitive des ponts ou simplement
de quelques légaux mais comment est ce
que ça fonctionne vraiment la raison
pour ça c'est parce que on est habitude
voire des structures avec leur centre de
gravité des différents éléments alignés
comme si on avait empilé un téléphone
portable et une bouteille d'eau la façon
intuitive de le faire c'est d'aligner
les deux offres et donc le centre de
gravité du téléphone aligné avec le
centre de gravité de la bei mais si on
veut faire une structure un peu plus
intéressante avec ça ce qu'on peut faire
c'est par exemple essayé de mettre le
téléphone désigné par rapport au centre
de la bouteille comme ça évidemment une
structure comme ça c'est pas stable si
j'enlève ma main le téléphone va tomber
mission qu on avait construit le
téléphone de façon à ce qu'ils ont un
poids prix lourd à la base de téléphone
juste ici à ce moment là la structure
serait stable ils feraient usage de ce
qu'on appelle la tantie grit est bon il
ya d'autres façons aussi que la
répartition des pots pour pour un
obtenir son peut jouer avec le design
des objets aussi un objet comme un ver
est un objet qu'on est habitué de voir
debout mais en changeant sa forme son
design en l'ajustant on peut on peut
faire tenir cet objet là dans une
position qui plus qu'autre et 8 yves on
peut on peut réaliser l'attend sécurité
avec des éléments vraiment de
différentes formes et c'est toujours
plus impressionnants de le faire avec
des objets usuels parce qu'on donne
l'impression de connaître site
ces objets là et lorsqu'on réussit eh
bien ça s'apparente pratiquement à de la
magie
un grand merci à luc langevin pour son
intervention je vous invite à le suivre
sur tous ces réseaux sociaux où il fait
souvent des démonstrations un peu folle
de tancer grit et je vous recommande
également de vivre l'expérience de son
nouveau projet un spectacle digital à
distance complètement novateur vous avez
les infos en lien dans la description en
parlant de magicien je vous faire voir
un tour de magie et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi il fonctionne contre
votre intuition et jeunes entrepreneurs
nous sert pour toi aussi tu veux
réfléchir mieux et plus vite des
villages en apprenant tout en rigolant
eh ben c'est possible et c'est
maintenant essayer avec fabien olicard
avec son spectacle d'humour et le
mentalisme dans toute la france en
tournée mais aussi en belgique en suisse
et soit doux au zénith de paris l'autre
à novembre
moi je vais avoir les neurones yvon
petit lait comme des pop corn peut-être
que tu vas beaucoup rigolé et surtout tu
vas avoir du mentalisme est assez
bluffant et même toi peut-être tu vas te
bluffé utilise fabien olicard c'est du
mentalist pas d'état plus récent
spectacle en tournée dans toute la
france mais surtout au zénith de paris
le 20 novembre
ça va être incroyable bourdois parce que
toutes les informations sont de la
description des trois hôpitaux de tout
acquis mais si je traduis show obligés
d'attendre que tu parles pour traduire
sinon on va voir que je traduis de la
merde in the days dans la description
traduit bien une plage les faits en
français ça peut occuper un zombie non
mais c'est bien
[Musique]
tout à l'heure nous allons faire des
expériences de physique dont le résultat
va nous surprendre c'est à dire vous
surprendrez me surprendre moi aussi
pourquoi parce que notre cerveau
contient des schémas qu'ils croient
comme étant vrai l'intuition c'est la
somme de toutes les expériences que nous
avons vécu traitée par notre esprit pour
établir des règles qu'ils considèrent
comme étant la vérité
les magiciens ils exploitent ces
raccourcis du cerveau s'est raccourcie
de l'intuition et surtout ses failles
que nous avons tous en commun pour mieux
réussir à nous surprendre
la fin d'un tour de magie ce n'est parce
que notre intuition avait prévu du coup
on est bluffé là pour la suite voir
comme comme tu sais c'est la vidéo sur
les trucs un peu contre intuitif il ya
un truc hyper contre-intuitif c'est le
bonneteau petit décès que tu tues tu
prends par exemple une rouge et de noir
tu vois tu dis la carte gagnante c'est
la rouge par exemple
donc je mets la rouge au milieu là 2,9
te fait pas le tour c'est juste pour
expliquer ce qu'ils connaissent pas mais
tu as une noire une noire ici times
rouge dans la rouge de la roja et frais
ça je voyais j'irai où est la route par
exemple est allé moi je suis allée
exactement pas là tu vois ça va très
très vite le bonneteau l'album voilà ça
c'est la même chose mais sans blessure
de mormal jeu c'est normal je peux aussi
ne se vend pas son nom mais sait pas
encore où et la rouge puisque remontera
là elle est là
alors mais même là je crois que je vais
aller en butte à des noirs alors en fait
pourquoi ça marche contre notre
intuition parce que ça exploite
certaines failles de ce que tu crois
avoir perçu est ce que tu crois voir
comme logique tu vois les passes très
classiques latins la rouge la noire et
la rouge hockey ici au milieu on met la
noire ok je peux vérifier
tu vérifiera que c'est faux et ce qui
est fort ce qui est fou c'est que la
jetée mille l'attention dessus
mais si on en avait pas parlé si on
avait fait ça juste en discutant comme
ça t'as pas forcément de doute pour le
cerveau parce qu'elle est vraiment là et
pourquoi c'est ça fonctionne en contrats
de mission je te le dis dans quelques
secondes
ok je vous en parle mais juste après
c'est pourquoi nos élites pour qu'il
reste forte je te fais un bon taux hyper
content sur 30 contre intuitif et rapide
quand même on joue contre l'intuition
d'accord donc méfie toi de ton intuition
mais la carte noire au milieu déjà là
ton intuition te dis la triche est ok
mais aller au milieu d'un décor est là
du coup ton intuition te dit de me faire
confiance
non mais en fait j'ai déjà retourner
maintenant je te refais en plus long je
te mets une rouge au milieu olympien ton
intuition te dis qu elle allait alors
elle à l'envers par rapport aux autres
cartes
we had à l'envers ça c'est bon mon
intuition les basiques
ok les basiques par contre ton intuition
devrait se fier à la règle de départ de
la carte noire est toujours au milieu ok
donc en gros tu as une rouge et de noir
non de rouge et noir attend un premier
avec ça en fait à une carte noire de
cartonnera jim magilton la raquette à
trois cartes noah s'est moqué soldes sud
a donc noir une rouge ou sol dessous des
cartes du casse et au milieu tu as la
rouge croquer et là ton intuition noir
la cie les tons addition te dis allez
toujours au milieu non mais j'ai vu avec
des roues
imbécile anouar el t'embête je l'enlève
et c'est réglé comme ça il nous reste
deux cartes au 1 4 et 1 6 ok là ton
intuition et li nan nan mais si y'a deux
cas ils ont une intuition de départ te
rappelle qu'au départ il ya une carte
noire un soir au milieu de deux cartons
rouges ok comment s'appelle ça c'est
faible 1 c'est pas très fort c'est pas
les réformes et ça c'est contrainte à
déclarer aussi là-bas laquelle six hélas
vraiment c'est à se financer tout juste
cinq ans comment fonctionne ce truc
c'est quand même fou mais ton cerveau en
fait il fait une impression rétiniennes
de cette forme là et se dit ok ça c'est
la logique effet seulement ouais c'est
la logique c'est la règle ça veut dire
que si on retourne tout ça doit avoir la
même forme c'est logique c'est la règle
en vrai si on retournait sans rien
bouger sans manipulation on devrait être
dans cet état
d'accord c'est dire notre cerveau il
préfère une figure qui est fausse ils se
disent assez vrai plutôt que la vraie
figure qui ferait ça weezy non mais là
c'est faux c'est pas bon
dans les années 1900 arthur good alias
tom type proposer des expériences en
tant que magicien scientifique son but
c'était d'émerveiller les gens pour les
amener à s'intéresser aux sciences et à
essayer de les comprendre ils voulaient
perturber leur confiance en leur
intuition pour aiguiser leur esprit
critique depuis toujours les magiciens
s'intéresse à l'intuition spontanée du
cerveau et pm s'ils sont pas chercheurs
ou scientifique
leur expérience nous sont toujours
profitable
le moment où notre sens de
l'interprétation pose réellement
problème c'est dans le traitement de
plusieurs données en même temps le plus
fréquent d'entre eux vient de notre
interprétation des statistiques comme on
peut en avoir par exemple par les médias
on a beaucoup vu ça ces derniers mois
toi même tu sais sommes nous vraiment
capable d'interpréter des statistiques
pierre cros ses mémoires de la chaîne
car cross
ouais exactement experts croient au même
dieu j'ai deux chaînes oui c'est vrai tu
d'ailleurs tu m'invites en tant que
quatre ans en tant que père quand même
mieux entendre car cross volume 2 pc
moins cher à ce jour c'est beaucoup
moins cher
est-ce que tu connais l'illusion de
de corrélation ou le biais de
corrélation d'ailleurs way secondes
c'est un truc ça ça va tu maîtrises en
vrai c'est ce sont des statuts comme ça
ouais bien sûr que bien dans le champ
c'est parfait c'est ça a été un truc
découvrant 67 par chapman et chapman et
ils sont aperçus que en vrai on n'est
pas capable avec notre cerveau de lire
des statistiques
tu vois on n'est pas capable d'avoir le
résultat pourquoi ils nous insultent
n'est pas capable de les comprendre
alors moi je peux tu vois ça ces deux
courbes de deux choses différentes
il ya une corrélation à 95% est ce que
tu penses que ses courbes sont liés que
l'une impact l'autre alors je pense que
tu essayes de me faire dire que oui que
non que oui je peux dire que c'est non
et que finalement c'est oui donc pour
toi c'est oui au final est en fait tu
essaies de me faire dire oui mais c'est
non donc toi là ces temps derniers mois
s'est noyée ces noms sur sur les deux
clubs ne sont pas liés et c'est vrai
elles ne sont pas liés chaque ruck parce
que sinon les intérêts de cette vidéo se
tape des changes donc à la courbe verte
c'est l'importation de pétrole aux états
mais en fait c'est et s'est mis en
corrélation avec le nombre
d'automobilistes décédé en se prenant un
train dans la gueule d'accord sur
quasiment rien à voir sauf si le train
transporte des barils de pétrole venant
suivi par les petits malfrats en voiture
qui veulent le volet et qui du coup de
n'évite pas le train donc année par
année on prend les chiffres on les
compare et on s'aperçoit qu'à 95% ça se
suit et ça c'est hyper fort c'est le
genre de truc qui ont démontré de chacun
des chapman c'est à dire que là ok on
sait que ça n'a vraiment rien à voir
mais si je te mets je sais pas moi une
maladie en ce moment est un médicament
lambda qui se mettraient en ce moment on
pourrait tirer des conclusions dans bay
c'est sûr ça marche mais on n'a pas
assez de brûler pour juger nous autres
qui ne sommes pas spécialistes doublé
cette semaine au petit schéma là où
c'est ça ouais en fait j'en ai plein
d'autres des comme ça qui sont très
cools l'âge et le nombre de pacs est
très cool les gens décident épanouie à
paris
après tomber la bateau qui m'a refait tu
vois ok pardon j'ai la gueule et alors
que franchement je ne sais vraiment et
le kentucky qui tu étais un peu croient
en plus ce sont les scores plus comme
c'est l'état du kfc genou et moi
j'imagine les mariages dans les caves
c'était vraiment beaucoup de références
qui elle a nourri diot quand même genre
pouvait souvent donc tout ya des gens
qui se marient dans le kentucky
on peut le voir un plus on a deux
personnes décédées de noyade après être
tombé d'un bateau de pêche moi c'est
plus l'un vers ce que je vois à plus la
personne décédée de noyade plus grosse
peuple le country qui exactement on va
aller un peu plus loin pierre il ya 1314
personnes des femmes exclusivement ci
ont été suivis pendant vingt ans parce
qu'on voulait c'est une vraie druide on
voulait voir lesquels avaient le plus
gros taux de mortalité est ce que c'est
et chez les fumeuses ou chez les non
fumeuses et là je te présente ce qu'on
appelle le paradoxe de simpson c'est le
résultat final qui va contre ton
intuition sûrement puisque on voit que
nos gencives en mer - c'est le taux de
mortalité après 20 ans
combien d'entre elles sont mortes après
20 ans et parmi ceux combien d'entre
elles combien été funeste combien
étaient pas fumeuse mais au bout de 20
ans ou après 20 ans de l'âge de 20 ans
là c'était en fait ils ont fait ça après
20 ans ils ont suivi cette étude pendant
20 ans donc il ya plus de morts en effet
nous donc je mets vraiment la cigarette
au fond à fond à fond mais ça c'est
incroyable de se dire c'est ça les
chiffres et le paradoxe de simpson c'est
que si on prend maintenant les mêmes
données tranche d'âge par tranche d'âge
donc c'est la même étude que ces
raccords on voit que sur les 18 24
c'est les fumeuses qui mouraient le plus
sur les 25 34 et ap recréé près
équivalent mais c'était plus une
enfumeuse quand même et après sur les 35
44 s'était largement les fumeuses
ensuite largement les fumeuses largement
les fumeuses largement les fumeuses et
là c'est ce qui nous met dans d'ailleurs
c'est à peu près équivalent les plus de
75 ans on s'est aperçus qu'au dessus de
75 en un moment donné les gens meurent
d'accord est ce que ses 75 ans et plus
quand tu regardes ça qui te dis toujours
si les fumeurs qui meurent le plus et
pourtant si on cumule toutes les données
ça donne ça où tu en as besoin
en fumée ce qui va le plus alors là je
vais pas te tape à tapas le truc qui te
permet de la voir le truc qui
permettrait de l'avoir c'est de savoir
combien de personnes ont été suivies
dans cette tranche d'âge
combien dans cette tranche d'âge
convient dans cette tranche d'âge et le
fait est que là dans cette tranche d'âge
ils ont suivi beaucoup plus de non
fumeuse que de fumeuses
en gros là je te dis de donner des
chiffres au pif mais ils ont peut-être
suivi 500 non fumeuse voix pour 15
fumeuses
ok ok donc quand tu fais ça ça nous fait
le même truc mais quand il additionne
tous les chiffres
du coup ça fait exploser les non
fumeuses qui sont mortes parce qu'elle
était beaucoup plus présente ici que ici
mais quand tu vois un truc comme ça à
paraître dans la presse
ils vont te dire c'est des vrais données
s'arrêtaient dai consacre aux gros
journal parce que si ça découle les
pages c'est juste article c'était
l'article encore et ça ça s'appelle le
paradoxe de simpson et je vais vous
expliquer un peu plus longuement
commencé à fondre je pourrais regarder
la vidéo figurait tout cas tu te
l'envoie à préparer grâce à ce que nous
venons de voir s'appelle le paradoxe de
simpson pas au maire évidemment mais
bien edouard simpson un statisticien qui
en 1951 à démontrer nos conclusions
intuitive erronée vis-à-vis des
statistiques
depuis on appelle ça le paradoxe de
simpson
voici une expérience simple qui vient
d'une vraie étude
un exemple simple venant d'une vraie
étude montre que sur ces deux
traitements pour les calculs rénaux là
et efficace à 79% alors que le 2e léa
83% et pourtant les chiffres sont justes
mais vous auriez peut-être intérêt à
opter pour le premier traitement car si
on segmente les résultats avec d'autres
critères
il s'avère que le premier est efficace à
93% pour des petits calculs contre 87%
pour le deuxième et le premier est
efficace à 73% contre les gros calculs
contre 69% pour le deuxième voilà le
paradoxe si on segmente les résultats
alors le premier traitement est toujours
plus efficace que le deuxième mais si on
fait la synthèse des résultats alors on
a l'impression mathématiques au final le
deuxième traitement est le meilleur
pourquoi ça fait ça
parce que le premier traitement et d
utiliser sur 87 personnes pour les
petits calculs rénaux contre 270
personnes pour le deuxième traitement
maintenant prenons en compte que ce sont
les calculs les plus faciles à soigner
et inversement le premier traitement a
été utilisée sur 263 personnes pour les
gros calculs contre seulement 80
personnes pour le deuxième traitement et
ce sont les calculs les plus difficiles
à soigner comme le total final a été
calculée avec tous les cas ils n'ont pas
une moyenne de 2 statistiques que je
viens de vous citer alors on a une
inversion des résultats c'est ce qui
conduit au paradoxe attention c'est à
vous dans quelques instants je vais
mettre votre sens intuitif à l'épreuve
je vais vous poser six questions mais
faites attention parmi elles il y en a
qui sont cachés et qui ont une réponse
un peu contre intuitive je peux buzz et
moi nous savons c'est un problème ça
c'est quoi vas-y question vas-y hockey
question numéro in c'est la plus dure
ils voulaient l'expliquerai qu'à la fin
un agriculteur à 100 kg de pommes de
terre celle déjà bravo ski bosses tout
seul et ça c'est toujours kiffé 100 kg
il ya 100 kg de patates
elles sont composées à 99 % d'eau est
important de matière sèche il est laid
s'il attend un peu l'eau s'évapore un
peu du coup elles sont composées à plus
que 98 % d'eau et du coup qu'elle est là
le poids des patates au final mais il ya
toujours 100 kg étayent son propos voilà
c'est le pourcentage
c'est le pourcentage qui a bougé mais ça
veut dire que la masse à la bouche et 5
c'est ça mais je sais pas l'expliquer en
fait la pomme de terre se transforme en
dehors des régates la pomme de terre n'a
pas changé de poids de deux matières
mais les deux pour cent de matières sont
égales à 1 kg du début parce que peu
n'ont pas bougé exit donc ça fait plus
que la moitié n'ont besoin comme 50 kg
c'est exactement ça bref bravo sierro
et les explications je voulais refaire
et mieux à la fois noël était bien là
telle est la ville la plus au sud entre
new york et rome
tu vois là aussi dans des intuitions tu
connais je suis maintenant j'ai je vois
que tu essaies de faire attention il n'y
a pas que des réponses contre active
ingénieurs et là j'ai bien compris que
c'était encore un tour de manipulation
au tour de passe passe
je dirais que c'est new york le plus au
sud exact correct je sais pas si vous
l'aviez aussi mais alors ça se joue à
pas grand chose là vous voyez peut-être
une image à l'écran qui vous fait voir
mais c'est bien new york est légèrement
plus de suite que rome ok question
numéro 3 will smith est il plus vieux ou
plus jeune que l'oncle fils à l'époque
de la série will smith fait quand même
très jeune physiquement alors qu'il
commence à être vieux
donc je pense que vous dites mais c'est
actuellement est plus jeune que l'oncle
au fil à l'époque mais c'est plus vieux
oui c'est ça ouais mais tout juste
quatrième question on est sur un sans
faute du cros est ce qu'il est possible
c'est un oui ou non qu'au moment de ta
naissance tué était la personne la plus
jeune de la planète est ce que quelqu'un
qui est né prématurément et les plus
jeunes que quelqu'un qui est né
normalement vous de 9 mois non tu n'es à
0 j'ai pas envie de commenter cette
musique
bonjour je m'appelle pierre g 0 secondes
mais tu parles quand même assez
prometteur pour le futur j'ai zéro
seconde
actuellement personne néanmoins il 0
secondes de retard et penser oui
ouais ouais c'est sortait juste c'est
juste drôle de mettre des questions
comme ça qu'on connaît question numéro 5
quand star wars et sorties ont
guillotiné encore des gens en france
vrai ou faux je pense qu'on s'en
servaient plus mais que jusqu'à
l'abolition de françois mitterrand qui
arrivent au pouvoir en 81
je sais pas quand est-ce qu'il est à
beaulieu ce qui m'a un peu bosser sur le
projet avant et le jeu fait bon jusque
il avait il y avait encore la guillotine
qui était dans les textes
ok mais vu utilisé
donc c'est faux pour le coup elle était
dans les textes - sans cervelle ouais
c'était 1,77 la dernière fois qu'on a
utilisé la guillotine après la sortie de
star wars c'est ou pas gentil mais c'est
surtout c'est pas longtemps t'imagines
moins de dix ans avant la naissance on a
encore des têtes en france c'est
restitue vois à quel moment il ya le
plus grande distance entre cléopâtre et
l'iphone ou entre cléopâtre et les
pyramides et là tu dis ouais mais là il
veut m'avoir parce que nana mais en même
temps comme si la dernière question je
sais pas regagné en même temps je sais
pas je te laisse réfléchir cheveux bruns
c'est bon moi j'ai ma réponse à ta
réponse j'ai ma réponse
bon bah je dirais quand même cléopâtre
pyramide contre intuition donc tout est
dit qu'il ya plus de temps entre le
début d'août qui a remise à flot par
l'iphone bah oui parce que là sinon ta
question et n'a sinon tu vois sur ton
choix ouais ok tu as raison il s'est
passé plus de temps entre le moment où
on a commencé à construire les pyramides
et cléopâtre contre 2,4 techniquement
sur une frise historique elle est plus
proche de l'iphone que des pyramides
voici donc des réponses contre intuitive
parce que notre cerveau ne prend pas en
compte toutes les données mais des
sensations de données pour cette
histoire de pommes de terre il fallait
non pas se concentrer sur la matière mid
l'eau mais sur la matière sèche qui elle
a un poids qui ne changent pas dans le
temps au départ on avait 100 kg de
pommes de terre pour 1 % de matière
sèche donc il y avait un kilo de matière
sèche
à la fin il ya 2 % de matière sèche ça
fait toujours un kilo alors avec une
simple règle de trois on sait qu'il
reste 50 kg de pommes de terre et de
pierres c'est que même en le comprenant
ayant le calcul ans au fond nous ça
reste perturbant comme résultat
on a vu plein de raisons de nous méfier
de notre intuition même avec des choses
aussi simples que la gravité mais en
creusant sur le sujet j'ai découvert des
trucs encore plus contre intuitif
en fait ça va au delà du contre intuitif
au dessus c'est ce que vous allez voir
voici une expérience de physique
amusante contre intuitive
si je pousse fort ce pendule ouais
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour tout le
reste d'après toi qu'est ce que ton
intuition te dis sincèrement sans penser
à essayer de dire attendez d'en du
contrat cultive donc ça va faire ci ou
ça
ils vont se synchroniser d'accord alors
première hypothèse ils ont synchronisé
et j'ai une deuxième question lequel des
deux s'arrêtera en premier d'après toi
alors s'ils sont synchronisés il
s'arrête un instant dans la finition
donc ils vont synchronisée et s'arrêter
en même temps roanne voici ce que nous
dit pierre je te propose de le prendre
et de le jeter un petit peu moins ça
change quelque chose
ça change parce que c'est parce que
j'avais prévu dans ma tête mais encore
mais je vois bien que c'est très
personnel donc du coup tu peux le faire
au québec ça bouge bien ok alors est ce
qu'ils vont faire réaliser c'est la
première question est bien lui s'est
arrêté complètement mais ils ont leurs
enfants aller ça fait un nouveau titre
etienne est en fait lui sa d'arrêter
complètement mais est en fait il se
transfère l'énergie comme ça mais attend
est ce que ça sera toujours non et on
vient de solutionner le problème
énergétique mondiale ça va s'arrêter
parce qu'en fait dès que tu as un
mouvement il ya une dépense d'énergie de
chaleur de friction et cetera qui fait
que ça peut pas être perpétuée mais en
soit s'il n'y avait pas trop tu mens qui
ait pas de perte d'énergie ça
continuerait éternellement
j'avais donc en guise de toit c'est p
égal mg je te trouve de plus en plus
intelligents j'aimerais bien qu'on
appelle car cross s'il vous plaît sa
performance en sélectionnant un surtout
que la fin est folle 1 tu vas voir
qu'est la 7e minute
sa mission en maintenant on va passer à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus ludique
car cross sur ces jobs très bien qu'on
écoute on va faire des bulles pourra
faire confiance à m
bull une nuit dans une pièce remplie de
bulles oui ok ok pour faire des bulles
pierre pour faire des bulles
il nous faut de quoi faire des buts car
je te laisse de la capsule et humer la
d'embauché ça fait des bulles pierre
ouais ok en gros d'après toi si on
trempe entièrement si on trompe toutes
les phases de dents ça va être quoi la
forme finale de la pub c'est à dire
comment va se mettre le savon sur cette
structure qui est un quadrilatère de
frank carrel
écoute moi bien c'est sensé sais pas
s'ils peuvent aussi rejoindre toutes les
deux semaines
ça va faire les techniquement en bray je
peux dire que dans le résultat final
tous les sommets sont effectivement ça
va faire coter côté côté mais à
l'intérieur des aussi ça je pense des
diagonales
on tente on tente comme on peut pas le
mettre en entier tu le tourner des lits
cat man sur toutes les surfaces et en
fait ça fait les à grenade dont je te
parlais et voilà n'est pas les côtés
c'est incroyable ou pas il qu'un cube au
centre là c'est vide après autour c'est
fou et ça c'est en suspension tout seul
c'est en suspension totale et en vrai
c'est parce que le savon cherchent à
utiliser le moins de surface possible
pour toucher tout le côté de la tête où
la miniature et je rêvais de le faire
donc j'écris tout une vidéo prétexte à
trouver encore du coup d'éclat pince
ouais
n'est ce pas ce qu'on aimerait doubler
sur voila c'est beau bravo de gameiro ce
monsieur pierre cros c'était un plaisir
de nous avoir avec nous merci d'être
venu faire ses expériences tout le merci
fabien merci de me recevoir merci à
toute la chaîne faut me garder parce
qu'on pense que c'est qu'une seule tête
mais il ya énormément de monde a
énormément merci à toute l'équipe
merci pierre merci à toi
contrairement à ce que croyait notre
intuition la nature ne cherche pas à
faire joli ou à remplir quoi que ce soit
au contraire elle cherche à utiliser le
moins d'énergie possible en minimisant
au maximum les surfaces qui l'utilisent
pour la bulle en y réfléchissant on
comprend que le moyen le plus simple de
relier plusieurs villes entre elles
n'est pas de relier chaque ville à une
autre ville mais bien de faire partir un
chemin de chaque ville qui va se
rejoindre en un carrefour commun c'était
logique mais pas intuitif merci à toute
l'équipe pour ce nouvel épisode merci à
fanny à la production à loïc à la
réalisation merci aussi à pierre cros
avec qui je fais des enquêtes de couple
approximatif sur sa chaîne
je vous invite à regarder ses vidéos le
lien vers sa chaîne et dans la
description penser à liker cette vidéo à
vous abonner pour pas rater des
prochains épisodes et tous les anciens
épisodes sans dans la description
alors sommes nous condamnés à subir nos
mauvaise intuition faut-il au contraire
les écouter existe-t-il des systèmes
pour empêcher notre cerveau de faire les
mauvaises hypothèse vous aurez la
réponse à ces questions il ya bien
d'autres dans les prochains épisodes de
matière grise
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]